I'm very sad to be saying goodbye to my
family Kunal Nayyar reacts to Big Bang
Theory coming to an end I'm sad to say I
taught him as a mouse
he caught up with the 37 year old actor
during the Kershaw's sixth annual
ping-pong for purpose tournament where
he shared his feelings on the show
ending after season 12
that's bittersweet obviously I'm ready
for the next phase of my life 12 years
you know I'm at the same time I'm very
sad to be saying goodbye to my family we
just it all happened yesterday so I'm
trying to process all of it all I know
is this gonna be the season the way that
we're ever gonna do actually our last
taping is on my birthday so it'll be an
interesting interesting like we're
family we spend a lot of time together
we were there when we found out together
and we're there to support each other
and that's all that's all there is to it
really that's why we've survived for
this long is because we love each other
you know I never knew that I'd be in a
position to change people's people's
life you know like I have a job you know
and now and now to be in a position
where I've been able to change people's
lives for the better and make people
laugh in a world that is so sort of
politicized right now for people to just
have an escape and to watch something
funny to inspire kids to to study
science to become astrophysicists to
help people who have been sick you know
whose last wishes were to come and spend
time with the cost those types of things
are all of all the things that I'm gonna
hold on to really
[Music]